[Music]
let's go to casey in raleigh north
carolina what's up casey
hi dr john how are you i'm so good how
about you
i'm doing pretty good um i love your
show so much happy to talk to you today
hoping you can help me a little bit i
don't know about that but thank you for
loving the show that makes me happy
yeah
well so it's gonna start out sounding
very um uh trivial but we'll get into it
a little bit so we currently have um a
disney trip planned for may
um which we've had to rebook two times
because of covid but um
we're really excited
except for i'm also extremely terrified
because of my son my um oldest son
i'm really nervous that he's going to
kind of ruin our trip um
i know this sounds horrible
not at all but not at all talk to me
about what's going on
um
so
every time that we've taken him on a
trip um you know we go into it with with
really high hopes and good expectations
kind of trying to lay the groundwork um
but he
is very controlling and
when he's not in control of situations
he can become
very defiant and kind of downright mean
extremely volatile and just very hard
for him to
regulate his feelings
how old is he a lot he's almost nine so
he'll be nine um in april of this year
so
um
and i just feel like the whole family is
always kind of walking on eggshells with
him and
like constantly trying to navigate
situations so we don't trigger him and
um you know so
i just constantly feel like i'm trying
to unravel a puzzle of like his heart
and mind and
i don't know how a lot of times sorry if
i'm getting a little emotional no it's
hard
yeah and his sister
who is she just turned six
she is the complete opposite she is so
go with the flow she's easy going but i
also kind of you know
look at her sometimes and
i see her when he goes into this these
you know heightened
deregulated emotional
places that she just kind of kind of
goes into a shell a little bit or
disassociates a little bit and just kind
of like goes into her own little world
where she's almost
very unresponsive
so responsive you know
tell me about the i'm sorry to interrupt
you tell me about
tell me about home life
is there chaos in home
i mean
i don't want to say yes but
i mean if it's not say no if it is say
yes
i mean i don't know that it's chaos it's
just busy there's a we're we're very
busy my husband and i we both work
um quite a bit um
you know we
we always have something going on i
wouldn't say it's chaotic it's just
i feel like we're constantly trying to
and not discipline him but like
regulate him daily and it's it's
actually kind of put a strain on the
entire family
um so over time what you've described to
me is both with him and with your
daughter
are two
two response systems
to the same issue
and
i'll simplify it here but
you've we've got a fight flight or
freeze or fawn response system
when things get chaotic when our bodies
feel out of control
or unsafe
and for a kid a lack of connection is
unsafe
a lack of
really firm boundaries i know where i'm
anchored in here
their body says sound the alarms we're
not safe things aren't okay
a
marriage of two parents who are not on
the same page or who are running a gun
in who are chaotic who have things going
on behind closed doors
that tells a childhood body you are not
safe
and this i must have control this unregu
this dysregulated
um i will get oh i will find a way for
you to see me
is a is a biological response it's off
it's rarely a in fact i i struggle with
even character issue for an
eight-year-old this is his body taking
over and then you got a daughter who
knows i'm gonna disappear
i'm gonna i'm gonna vanish
saying i mean you're talking about the
freeze response right uh and if you have
a third kid that may nuzzle up to you
and that might be the fond response
that's their way i'm gonna get super
close to my the person who i'm terrified
of or the situation i'm terrified of and
i'm gonna love them through this and if
i'm really close and i'm in love then
they won't they won't hurt me i won't be
hurt
it feels something environmental going
on here
um and that's that may be for a
different phone call
but
what i
this is one of the curses i mean i just
wrote a book about this almost this
exact thing there's a couple of chapters
about this very thing which is
we have just kept running
faster and faster and faster
and we've without even meaning to
created a world that our bodies cannot
exist in and then we bring kids into it
and
man we throw diagnosis at them we throw
behavior plans at them we throw school
punishment at them we throw all kind of
stuff at them
and if we distill it way down
their behavior is a language and what
they're telling us is i'm not i don't
feel safe
wow and it's it's
i mean it is trust me i've been there
too i've been there too
does that ring a bell with you or am i
out to lunch and feel free to say you're
nuts
no i mean it does ring a bell with me
however
you know we have i feel like and
but maybe it's just because i'm trying
to figure out like you said a diagnosis
in a way because he's like an angel at
school like anyone outside of
our immediate family and maybe my
grandparents and like sister and
sisters
like nobody else would know anything
like this about it so what does he get
at school
structure
firm structure very very clear
boundaries
a teacher shows up every single day with
the same routine
yeah there's no race to this and then
we're gonna go to that and then hey
everybody's gotta get up cause we all
know we just go when the bell tells us
or we all go it's it's 11 10. we all
stand up we go to the line we stand
there
so school is a highly
structured safe place and i don't say
safe place like in the awoke you know
get in a box so nobody can say mean
things safe
safe physiologically biologically for
his body
adults are slow they talk quiet they
look you in the eyes they get down on
your level
you hear what i'm saying it's it's these
tiny behaviors
and i'm telling you this not to guilt
nobody wins with a guilt trip that's
what i'm trying to do here
right it was a shape-shifter moment when
i realized the way i was doing life was
contributing to the chaos of other
people's lives around me
and i wept it was hard i had to grieve
it because i didn't mean to be doing
that i thought i was getting everybody
amped up and we're going we're gonna
we're gonna
we're gonna
man we're gonna slide into the end of my
life with no tread left on the tires
we're doing it all working at all and i
realized i was uh uh i was like being
married to a taser
everybody right and so i tell you that
that that's a separate question you even
called me
how's your marriage and i'll just be
totally honest
y'all good
no okay there you go and that's that may
be a third separate we'll just make you
a regular on the show
right i could use that actually probably
but like i i've picked up some of the
things from your show that i've been
trying to do like the physical touch
you know like making sure and and we've
been to a lot of like play therapy and
like relational therapy types of things
to try to like you know figure this out
a little bit and you know he loves like
you know we'll go to bed before we go to
bed at night we like make a pizza on its
back which is so random but like
it calms him you know it's the touch and
then like the thing that you've said
about putting the hand on the back of
the neck and 30 second hug we've really
been trying to do that too but what
other ways can
like i mean obviously it's a big
question but like how can we start
making him feel more safe and secure
without just like both quitting our jobs
tomorrow you know two things number one
and i'm just putting this out there one
of you may have to take a reduced load
or do something different that might
come to it
first and foremost when somebody calls
me and says hey i need a book about
anxiety for my kid
or what is your recommendation for
childhood anxiety
the first thing i say is fix your
marriage
and not one person has ever come back
when they asked me that question and
said dude my marriage is great it's
perfect why
now i'm not saying that um
there's a one-to-one
causal relationship here the correlation
in my experience is very very high
and so the greatest gift because here's
the thing when you're in a marriage
that's rocky that's messy
that's even even if it's not rocky or
messy
and you're laying in bed at night next
to somebody that you love and you feel
totally alone and i know you know what
i'm talking about right
when you feel that your body becomes
dysregulated
what you have is you've got years of
maturity you've got professional
responsibilities and you've got muscle
that you can gut it out but a kid's body
absorbs every second of that
and so if you've got two adults living
in a house who are co-managers but they
are not they are not intimate and that
both sexually and
psychologically and spiritually if
they're not on the same page the kids
absorb that tension
they absorb it and so when somebody says
hey how do i help my kids got anxiety
kids really anxious all the time they're
running i always tell fix your marriage
go see somebody today
because your kids are gonna anchor into
that and a good marriage at home
there's some great studies on kid
happiness
in third world countries where there's
deep poverty
but parents are connected
and the kids are anchored in so tight to
that thing and then they can swing down
and act like kids and be maniacal and go
through kids stuff and fall and break
their arms and fail and screw up because
man i am tethered into something really
tight
but then you come over here man we got
all the money in the world but we're
we're like i say we're co-managing our
houses we are not in intimate
relationships with our spouses anymore
and the kids are just free-falling
and then i i absolutely 1000 know cause
i've been there
how hard this is to hear
i know it
when it comes to the disney world thing
this is a uh
was a shape shifter moment for me um
sitting down with a child psychologist
child counselor that i just love and
have high high respect for and she put a
lot of time and energy into mentoring me
um
two important things we number one we
always as a parents we get this picture
in our head
of what a family or our family is
supposed to and or gonna do
and then come hell or high water we make
sure this freaking thing happens
and
the second thing is is we tell our kids
what they are gonna love
i just did this the other day we had a
foot of snow here in nashville and i
told my daughter you are gonna love me
shoving you down one of our hills in a
thing just trust me
she hated every second of it and i
should have listened to her
right now there's those times you need
to push him and say right so that's what
i'm talking about
when i take my my daughter let's say say
hey we're gonna go to a movie in 10
minutes in
she says
i i i don't feel good can we go
somewhere else
my temptation is to say
no i paid for this movie we're watching
this movie what she's really trying to
tell me in her limited words is i'm
dysregulated this is too much
stimulation i'm overwhelmed i really
like to just go walk around a park with
you
and i should have gone to the park in
the first place i'm the one that was
like no you should do the movie too so i
would tell you
if you can't
if you're a family unit
and that includes all of your kids if
going to disney world doing disneyland
is not gonna be a net benefit don't go
don't go don't don't torture each other
to just to say we went to disneyland
or so that y'all can post about it or
tell your friends or it's a status
don't do it if you and your husband want
to go go by yourselves and don't even
tell your kids just go
but there's a picture in your head and
now it's been worse because it's been
canceled twice
stupid
this is i i don't give a crap this
vacation is happening kids we're right
and i get i get that
if your eight-year-old's gonna be
miserable and your daughter's gonna have
fun until she's not
don't go
go camping at a k you know what we did
last from vacation last year we went to
a koa it cost us like 28
and my kids are still talking about that
vacation and i felt like a sham of a
husband and a dad i felt so lame and now
dude i'm all i'm koa all day i'm gonna
get koat tattooed on my chest it's so
awesome right not really right but it
was so lo-fi so chill and it was
incredible because we did the vacation
that our family needed not the one that
was going to get me acclaim with my
friends and community and that i had in
the back of my head
yeah i mean to be fair they've been
saying they want to go for the past two
years oh what kid doesn't want to go of
course
of course and my kids also tell me that
they would love love love ice cream for
dinner
and they all i also know no you don't
because you're gonna wake up tomorrow
you can feel terrible
and you're not gonna sleep tonight and
you're gonna be miserable at school and
you're gonna get in trouble and and
so there's part of that parent as
parents
in childbirth she was discernment right
but i get that no kid is gonna be like i
don't want to go to disneyland are you
crazy no no kid will say that but they
will fight and claw and scream and throw
fits and feel unsafe
i would love for y'all to go man i'd
love for my family to go
um we're saving up to go someday i would
love to
um but man i i got to make sure
everybody's involved
will you heal your marriage or were you
at least leaning into that
yeah i want i want that for you i want
that for your husband i want that for
your whole family squad man you're super
worth it
for real
and have you taken him to get tested
your son
oh you got lots of them lots okay and
i hear this all the time you got all the
diagnosis in the world all the whatever
plans and all this is and that's
there's a core issue here my guess is
and again you and i are talking for 10
minutes on the radio my guess is
um on the podcast here my guess is
there's a chaos in the family system
somewhere maybe you just sit down with
your husband tonight and say hey
i talked to this guy i talked to a coach
today
like things feel off the rail like we
are running so fast i miss you
hey what happened we got to own what
happened and
man can we just tell each other the
truth i'm not okay and we're not okay
and i don't think that you're okay you
all start there
and
so often the kids stuff begins to take
care of itself when mom and dad are
super locked in